i couldn't find the comment but someone  commented in my last video saying you  didn't put that on your resume did you i  found this especially funny because i  did in fact put this on my resume you  can see that was my last job and here i  have tic toc star as my current role i  know you said 100 000 followers on tick  tock is not impressive but i wanted to  know what about 105 000 so you could you  could say i'm a big deal it's whatever  here i have absolutely no shame which  seems to be good for the internet  someone say a bold move to quit your job  to be a tic toc star i would say not  afraid of failure so i know it's a  shocker that i am still unemployed but  feel free to email me at  justpearlythings.com